ciao a tutti e non avendo grandi teorie
sul lavoro ho pensato di raccontarvi 5
spicco le storie della mia vita
lavorativa cinque storie che fotografano
le grandi lezioni che io ho imparato in
questo percorso e per farlo mi sono
fatta aiutare da nicholas testa che è un
bravo grafico illustratore quindi che
racconta che racconterà dietro di me
appunto visivamente queste storie la
prima storia è ambientata al corriere
della sera cronache italiane una distesa
infinita di scrive niente alle quali io
sono un puntino invisibile una stagista
passano le settimane passano i mesi e
diventa sempre meno invisibile ma ciò
non impedisce che il finale sia questo
cioè arrivederci e grazie alcuni vengono
assunti però la maggior parte di noi
ovviamente riceve soltanto una pacca
sulla spalla
niente di strano se non fosse che questa
storia nella mia vita all'inizio succede
tantissime volte questo scava una
voragine nella mia autostima enorme una
voragine che all'esterno si manifesta
con i soliti luoghi comuni e mattia che
su tutti raccomandati ma si sono degli
yesmen io sono uno spirito libero e così
via
fin quando non arriva una persona nella
mia vita a un mentore che mi pone una
domanda semplice mi dice ma davvero
avresti voluto essere assunta in quel
posto dove montano assoluto e dico ma
veramente no però avrei voluto che
almeno me l'avessero chiesto in questo
piccolo dialogo in realtà è insita la
prima grande lezione che avevo imparato
nella mia vita professionale cioè
attenta a ciò che desideri perché ci
sono dei desideri veri dei desideri
importanti dei desideri che bruciano di
passione e così dei tiri sono quelli a
cui noi attendiamo la nostra idea di
felicità e che non genera e ci rendono
felici anche se non si realizzano
poi ci sono invece dei desideri mar si
desideri che noi facciamo più perché non
so voglio andare una soddisfazione ai
nostri genitori oppure per avere un
riconoscimento sociale per poter dire sì
beh anch'io sono assunto anche un posto
di lavoro
ebbene spesso e volentieri a noi non è
chiara la differenza tra questi due
desideri e prendiamo per buoni desideri
march mentre in realtà questa differenza
è chiarissima che ci sta di fronte a chi
li deve realizzare quei desideri e tutto
ciò è una fortuna perché la più grande
sfortuna che ci potrebbe succedere e che
là fuori ci vengano realizzati quei
desideri march perché questo ci
condannerebbe all'infelicità la seconda
scena si svolge in un appartamento un
micro appartamento per due ci vivo con
il mio futuro marito
e siccome nessuno mi ha assunto sono una
freelance e passo tutto il tempo a
scrivere e mail
in quel periodo io sono famosissima tra
i miei amici perché ok nessuno mi assume
però tutti rispondono alle mie mail e o
chiunque scriva qualsiasi direttore di
giornale tutti quanti mi rispondono e mi
fanno lavorare o altro e in questa fase
della mia vita insomma io non capisco
perché effettivamente non riesco a farmi
rispondere ci ho riflettuto dopo e devo
dire che ho imparato alla seconda
importantissima lezione e cioè che il
miglior curriculum sono le idee in
quella fase io non avevo da vendere
grandi studi non abbiamo fatto grandi
esperienze allora avevo imparato un
trucchetto non dovevo presentarmi
dicendo chi ero
ma dovevo presentarmi dicendo cosa
pensavo che cosa potevo fare per quel
giornale quali idee potevo sviluppare e
il genere presentandomi in questo modo
riusciva a farmi ascoltare oggi che sono
dall'altra parte che riceve ogni giorno
decine e decine di curriculum
effettivamente io rispondo sempre a
tutti perché essendo stata una free
lenza e capisco quanto è importante
rispondere ma in genere risponde dicevo
dicendo
mandatemi delle proposte mandatemi delle
idee preferisco valutarvi su queste e vi
dico che su 100 curriculum che ricevo è
qui rispondo soltanto in 5 poi mi
mandano le idee perché le idee sono una
merce rarissima e che ce la fa benissimo
a metterle in campo a esporle senza aver
paura che gliele rubino perché un'idea è
meglio se viene rubata che se rimaneva
espressa la terza scena che che vi
racconto è ambientata invece a top girl
che è il primo giornale che mi trova a
dirigere a 30 anni
in realtà non è così strano dirigere un
king magazine a 30 anni all'estero
succede e in effetti a me succede in
un'azienda straniera
la cosa strana è che io mi trovo in
questo ruolo di direttore non so
assolutamente da dove iniziare
non ho idea di come si costruisca un
giornale
le opzioni grafiche non ho nozioni di
marketing
a quel punto sono nel panico totale e
per essere in un panico come quello che
ho provato io in quel momento in realtà
non bisogna soltanto insomma non bisogna
essere diventati direttore a 30 anni io
penso che anche un giovane la sua prima
occupazione
appena uscito dall'università si trova
in una situazione di spaesamento simile
perché l'università è chiaro non è molto
legata al mondo del lavoro e non ti
forma in una situazione del genere ha
illustrate fondamentalmente la prima
strada è quella di bluffare di fingere
di sapere tutti si aspettavano da me
risposte e io all'inizio ho cominciato a
percorrere quella strada cioè i lavori
esposti dice oh sì sì meglio quello di
pilato non capivo assolutamente niente
per fortuna per fortuna pian piano ho
cominciato a intravedere che c'era
un'altra strada e l'altra strada era
quella di non bloccare il mio processo
di formazione di continuare ad imparare
cioè di non smettere in pratica di
formarmi per paura di perdere
autorevolezza questo è l'errore più
grande che un giovane può fare è in una
situazione del genere dove non c'era
tempo per fare corsi dove non c'era
nessuno che mi potesse insegnare a fare
il direttore da chi poteva imparare e
qui viene la terza importantissima
lezione cioè che il maestro e il vicino
di scrivania
per me questa è una cosa fondamentale
perché tutti ci raccontano ci descrivono
i posti di lavoro come dei luoghi
terribili come delle arene di
competizione spietata
invece io nella mia storia ho avuto modo
di vedere che se tu cominci a trattare
tutti i tuoi colleghi come mai se come
persone straordinarie che provengono da
esperienze diverse delle quali imparare
quali abbeverarsi allora i luoghi di
lavoro diventano dei luoghi splendidi
dove la gente può crescere senza quasi
accorgersi di farlo la quarta scena si
svolge di nuovo a casa mia nel frattempo
ha avuto una bambina sono le 4 di notte
la bambina si sveglia fin qui tutto
normale
la cosa strana è che io non ho bisogno
di alzarmi dal letto perché io sono già
sveglia o meglio io sono ancora sveglia
perché non sono mai andato a dormire in
quel periodo io lavoravo di continuo
lavoravo 18 ore al giorno non mi fermavo
mai ero a geo era la mia seconda
direzione è proprio in quel periodo il
mio capo mi disse se analizzata ho
capito com'è che riesce
per creare consenso come che riesce
anche ad avere il consenso di persone
molto più grandi di te e che tu lavori
lavori tantissimo lavori quanto loro e
anche più di loro
e in effetti il mio capo aveva ragione
però io sbagliavo
il mio lavorare incessantemente era una
sorta di cappuccio benevolenza io volevo
quasi chiedere scusa per essere
diventato capo volevo dimostrare di
meritarmelo e quindi facevo sia il capo
che il ragazzo di bottega
cercavo sempre insomma di di creare
empatia con loro però in quel modo non
creava progresso perché mi impediva di
pensare e quindi qui la quarta
importante lezione della mia vita e che
non se li per sbaglio fidati non
sentirti un impostore c'è un pacchetto 6
e allora qual è questo perché qual è il
valore che può avere un giovane nel
mondo del lavoro perché un'azienda deve
investire su di un giovane di sicuro non
perché passi le notti a lavorare e
questa cosa l'ho capita alla quando sono
arrivata alla mia terza direzione la
direzione di cosmopolitan il giornale
era stato rilanciato era stato messo sul
mercato andava molto bene io mi stavo
annoiando
ora annoiarsi in un mondo come quello
dell'editoria che crolla giorno dopo
giorno perde pezzi continuamente è
davvero da irresponsabili e io mi
annoiavo perché pensavo che il mio
lavoro si esaurisse nel confezionare
buoni giornali e che finisse lì mi era
chiaro che il modello cioè il processo
che portava a quel prodotto era
sbagliato air anacronistico non aveva
nessuna possibilità di sopravvivere ai
tempi cioè non era minimamente
competitivo però pensavo che non fosse
compito mio cambiarlo mi sentivo
impotente di fronte a quel cambiamento e
anche in qualche modo
deresponsabilizzata per fortuna ancora
una volta nella mia vita ho avuto
qualcuno che mi ha dato due schiaffoni
belli forti e mi ha fatto capire che non
aveva nessun senso la mia presenza lì se
non avevo il coraggio di mettermi a
cambiare non i prodotti ma i processi
che portavano al prodotto perché proprio
questo l'essenza di avere un giovane in
un'azienda non che gli passi le notti a
colmare il gap di esperienza che lo
separa da quelli che hanno molta più
esperienza di lui un giovane deve
valorizzare con l'esperienza e degli
altri e deve portare valore la propria
inesperienza in che modo si porta valore
l'inesperienza rompendo gli automatismi
rompendo gli schemi che si sono
costruiti nel corso del tempo
rompendo le gerarchie pensando fuori
dagli schemi
questo è il valore di un giovane quando
io l'ho capito allora ho cominciato
prima nella redazione di cosmopolitan e
oggi nella redazione di donna moderna
per esempio ad agire sulla gerarchia
cioè quella struttura che in realtà ha
un senso perché ci permette di produrre
dei prodotti di qualità e di contenuti
però quella gerarchia quella piramide
spesso e volentieri ammazza l'idea mazza
la circolazione di idee allora io ho
cominciato a creare delle finestre in
quella gerarchia facendo respirare chi
sta sotto e facendo e facendo emergere
tutti quanti però senza distruggere del
tutto una struttura lavorativa come
quella un'altra caratteristica
soprattutto del mondo editoriale e
l'assoluta separazione praticamente tra
chi produce contenuti per uno per la
carta chi li produce per il digitale chi
li produce per il tablet e così via io
sto cercando faticosamente duramente di
portare tutti questi diciamo tutte
queste figure in un unico percorso in
un'unica persona in sostanza questo è un
lavoro difficilissimo ed è un lavoro ad
alto tasso di
di rischio cioè è facilissimo sbagliare
con questo lavoro è facilissimo fare
errori anche non rispettare le regole
però e per tanto tempo io non l'ho fatto
perché pensavo che là fuori tutti
stessero ad aspettare che facessi un
errore che io dimostrarsi di essere un
impostore appunto invece poi mi sono
accorta che non è affatto così e che
anzi ti perdonano molto più facilmente
di non aver rispettato le regole che di
non aver cercato di cambiarle cioè il
più grave errore che può fare un giovane
è quello di non osare non quello di
sbagliare perciò quello che so oggi è
che il coraggio di sbagliare è quello
che tutti si aspettano da noi